les Chéries 54 % des gens préfèrent
passer du temps avec leur téléphone
plutôt qu'avec leur partenaire mais
chance de partenaire non c'est une étude
c'est une étude qui vient de tomber
[Musique]
regardez 5h c'est le temps que nous
passons en moyenne quotidiennement sur
notre téléphone portable un téléphone
que nous consultons une centaine de fois
par jour et dont certains ont du mal à
se passer même lorsqu'ils font crac crac
badaabou allez sur 100 personnes combien
consultent leur téléphone pour qu'il
font crac crac
badabou et alors que 61 % des Français
estiment que leur conjoints passe trop
de temps sur leur smartphone on passe au
second plan quand il pose son smartphone
je sens qu'il a toujours envie d'y
retourner alors que son fils attend de
passer du temps avec lui selon une
récente étude cette addiction ferait
vivre un véritable calvaire à certaines
personnes puisque 54 % de la population
préférait passer plus de temps avec leur
téléphone plutôt qu'avec leur
partenairire qui est
d'accord qui est d'accord avec ça pa ah
moi je suisement d'accord enfin le
téléphone téléphone c'est trop important
Mo par exemple des fois quand je suis
avec mon mec on se fait des dates ouis
tik tookok ouais ça on se voit et en
fait on regarde tikt chacun d'autre côté
ah fort ou c'est quoi rapport a
royal on a changé elle est qui qui
g bien s c'est là qu'on voit tu
vois gap il y a un gap question
génération moi c'estu tellement addictif
le téléphone que même quand ma copine en
face quand j'ai quelque chose à lu
jeenvoie au lieu de lui parler tu veux
faire
je sûr que oui mais pourquoi tu me le
dis pas bah je sais pas j'étais sur mon
téléphone c'est plus Simp c'est quoi le
genre de message j'ai faim ouais j'ai
faim c'est quoi comme message que tu oui
j'ai envie de bouffer quelque chose ou
ou par exemple toujours toujours dans
toujours dans la délicatesse toi tu es
toujours j'ai envie de bouffer non non
mais lui t'en mets pas une dedans ce
soir c'est incroyable l'émission n pas
terminée non
plus pour vous si
P oui moi je fais les deux en même temps
je demande à ma meu de me raconter sa
journée je suis sur instant en même
temps je regarde
comm pourquoi faut faire les de même
c'est bien mais le téléphone c'est
devenu un truc on s' c'est horrible
quand tu parles à quelqu'un est sur le
téléphone vousêtes j sur
téléphone pas sur votre téléphone juste
pendant l'émission
qu jamais jamais jamais j souvent on
fait pas exprès on reste longtemps sur
le téléphone c'est après c'est le
partenaire qui dit sais que ça fait 45
minutes que mais comment tu peux bah tu
es arrivé l'émission a commencé et là tu
es encore sur ton téléphone et souvent
on fait pas gaffe on reste longtemps sur
notre téléphone sans faire gaffe on sent
que
vagal je mon pas bien envie ton sac les
Ch le gouvernement ne validera pas la
limitation de vitesse à 50 km/h sur le
périphérique parisien quel bonheur bravo
clé atttion persiste dit je le fais
quand même non non non elle le fera pas
je peux te dire que Clément B je le
connais le ministre délégé des
transports il est assuré que l'État ne
validera pas la limitation donc je peux
vous dire que c'est mort vous allez voir
si c'est pas validé par l'étatal je peux
vous dire est cuite une fois de plus
quel bonheur ah ça fait plaisir non mais
bravo
parisen parisiens j'en ai rien à [__]
j'appelle Clément B pour lui laisser un
message tu vis dire bravo sux ouais
j'appelle Clément bon j'en ai rien à
[__] j'appelle Clément bon allons
enfant de la j'appelle Clément sérieux
j'ai rien à foutreappelle Clément j'ai
tout le monde dans mon
t j'ai tout le monde dans mon t Mo
j'appelle je dire
bravo on va laisser un message tous
ensemble je vais twister même vous avez
tout le monde personne décroche
heour message et je vous rappelle
possible au
revoir monsieur le ministre Clément ba
Clément je voulais vous dire bravo bravo
pour la limitation de vitesse qui n'a
pas été accordé à 50 km/h sur le
périphérique parisien je jeaimerais tous
qu'on se lève et qu'on chante la mar
c'est yes pour Clément bon allons
enfants de la
Patrie le jour de
gloire merci c'est bon il a compris que
c'est la martiise merci Clément et bravo
bravo quel quel bonheur ce mec bravo
Clément bon on vous aime
bravo Clément bon très sympa bah voilà
ça c'est magnifique voilà ça c'est
magnifique ça voilà ça c'est beau bonne
nouvelle e toi qu'est-ce que tu veux ça
se fera que vous le vouliez ou non mais
ça se fera pas impossible fa que vous le
vouliez ou
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
Nonore mais arrête ça ne se fera pas non
non mais je t'explique si le
gouvernement veut pas c'est mort pas du
ressort du gouvernement problème tu
Paris ça passera pas c'est le préfet de
police et le pouvoir de police du maire
mais tu tu parles mais qu'est-ce que tu
racontes le préfet de police il va
suivre l'état qu'est-ce que tu RAC la
République c'est moi
est on Paris
Paris la dernière fois av perdu tuas
Paris quoi tu as perdu tuas perdu la
dernière fois j'ai
gagné ça rien à voir là c'est tu Paris
vas-y
nulouir de police
duouir de police ça passer pas tu verras
mois ça passera pas é on ver tu verras
donc une fois de plus à côté de la
person tu as je vais te dire un truc tu
as plus de chance de te marier avec
Fatou que ça passe donc pour te dire que
je peux te dire qu' il y a pe a il y a
peu de chance ça fait ça fait 10 ans
qu'on attend he vous verrez c'est quoi
le Paris qu'on soit témoins ah oui oui
le Paris bah le Paris c'est quand je je
vous le voyez plus en septembre mais si
c'est lui qui gagne le Paris qu'est-ce
qu'il fait qu'est-ce qu'il a gagne Paris
ouais qu'est-ce qu'il a il sera content
d'être là et puis voilà ça vait le
coupag non Paris combien Paris 100
balles ouais un dîner un dîner non non
c'est bon j'ai pas envie de dîner avec
toi c'est bon
c'est bon c'est bon ah vous avez vu il y
a plus d'un Français sur deux qui avoue
avoir déjà simulé en faisant crac crac
badabou est-ce que c'est c'est le cas
ici les mec il y en a un sur deux donc
c'est obligé franchement déoncez-vous là
non moi je ve pas pa scar bah toi dis la
vérité non mais quel rapport mais
qu'est-ce que j'ai fait moi qu'est-ce
qu'elle a c'est une question POS une
question j'ai envie de savoir de quoi
qu'est-ce qu'il y a est-ce que tu
simules mais elle est folle elle les h
comment homme simu vous AZ vu comment
parle che comment franchement mais si si
c'est moi j'avais des potes qui simul
comment tu peux simuler bah ils avaient
un pistolet à
haut non mais tout est dans le bruitage
ouis dans le bruitage exactement e ouais
les gars et ouais ouais tu crois quoi
crois quoi oui non pas vous pas vous pas
làdessusous faire on la sent pas votre
info même tu vois pas que marcanttoine
se sent pas bien comment voulez-vous que
je simule j'arrive déjà pas à bander
il des
charges marine Marc Antoine a les bonnes
infos sur les chroniqueurs non non mais
dites les vérités franchement mais c'est
les femmes la seule qui pourrait dire la
vérité ici c'est benim ah ouis mais
pourquoi
[Rires]
moi qu'est-ce que vous voulez dire comme
non je vou dire ma femme simule pas elle
simule pas ma femme j'en suis sûr elle
jouit jamais voilà donc
voà non mais sors sors sors allez sors V
V sors vite V sors vite c'est ta pire
émission de toute ta
vie pari par mais c'est bon je te jure
là c'est insupportable mais c'est nul
mais les mecs g narage quel chose jamais
vu
ça quoi même cardose est
meilleur encore
R
les mecs vous avez vu cette info en
Italie il y a un coiffeur trafiquant de
drogue qui a été démasqué par la police
parce qu'il recevait trop de chauve dans
son salon c'est incroyable pas
franchement c'est pas ouf ça ou si c'est
ouf le coiffur il aurait pu raser la
tête non je vois pas pourquoi mais c'est
déjà
chaudich oufce qu' raconte mais s rig
non mais là le problème c'est qu'ils
arrivé déjà chauve chez oui mais bon
entretenir le crâne je sais pas moi
j'eni
qui éta dans le salon de coiure bien
dégradé sur les
narines mag heureusement es là ce so
heureusement que es là parce que c'est
catastropique nafrage mais comment
il c'est
catastropique c'est vraiment nul ah vous
avez vu à Marseille de agents municipaux
menacé des enfantsant pour obtenir le
calme vousz vu ça
pas
si la cantine est censée être un moment
de pause et de détente pour les
écoliers un véritable scandale a éclaté
cette semaine dans un établissement
marseillais alors que des agents venus
remplacer du personnel en grève ont été
appelés pour surveiller les enfants ces
derniers se seraient montré intimidant
et menaçant avec les élèves qui devaient
patienter avant de pouvoir manger pour
ramener le calme les adultes leur ont
interdit de parler chuchoter et même
sourire de nombreux parents d'élèves
sont aujourd'hui en colère et affirment
que leurs enfants sont rentrés trs
bouleversé et stressé certains enfants
ont été très marqués et ont pleuré en
racontant ce qu'ils ont subi auprès de
ces personnes malveillantes une enquête
administrative a été ouverte depuis
l'incident
oui heureusement que la mairie a réagi
très vite et les parents d'élèves bien
entendu parce que c'est dingue quoi pour
remplacer des grevistes les deux agents
ils punissent les enfants ils les
menacent de rester les bras en l'air si
jamais ils font du bruit ils sont deux
les
pauvres son attendez attendez je peux
finir ou pas c'est de la fake news déjà
dans il tap un coup de bâton laisse
laisse laisse répond tu dis n'importe
quoi une fois de plus j'ai le communiqué
les parentsusez-moi non mais moi je j'ai
gardose aussi d'accord mais en tout cas
les parents les parents d'élèves et
membres de l'ADPF disent que durant
cette attente donc dans la salle d'une
cinquantaine d'enfants obligation de
rester silencieux interdit de chuchoter
même de sourire si un enfant fait du
bruit rester debout les bras en l'air
jusqu'à ce que ce soit son tour de
manger copier plusieurs fois des verbes
faire croire aux enfants qu'on leur met
des avertissements taper à coup de bâton
sur des objets piano cabane à
marionnette vitre pour exiger le silence
menacer les enfants qui ne faisaient pas
le silence de ne pas manger oui d'accord
CTA non mais d'accord sauf que c'est à
cause d'une grève d'accord il a fallu
faire
appel il y avait 100
gamins voilà et on a fait appel à deux
surveillants
pour évidemment qu'on a pas le droit
de des enfants mais vous êtes fous quoi
arrê arrête arrête tu tu traumatises les
gens tous les soirs mais hier hier tu
gueulais tu voulais que tous les enfants
puissent aller à la cantine aujourd'hui
tu dis que la cantine c'est l'enfer non
non non non ça n'a rien à voir arrêtez
oou j'appelle complément
[Rires]
d'enquête non mais c'eston ils avaient
préparé leur pique-nique de la veille
ils savaient très bien qu'il y aurait
que deux surveillants qui étaient là ils
sont s ils veulent faire respecter un
peu le le les par menent quand même de
dire de faire une main courante non mais
ils sont allés trop loin d'accord
ils sont rentrés en pleurant les enfants
C ils sont rentrés chez eux en pleurant
voilà non mais attendez il fa il faut
pas accabler ces pauvres agents
municipaux ils ont fait comme ils ont ça
serait ta fille qui rentre de l'école en
pleurant tu serais en train de cri des
enfants ils ont dit menacé de taper ou
non mais qu'est-ce qu'on on sait d'abord
pardon communiqué même la mairie le
reconnaî il y a une enquête
administrative tout le monde le
reconnait alors une réunion aujourd'hui
entre les parents d'élèves entre les
enseignants et la mère de Marseille on
va voir c'est une école un peu spéciale
une école qui applique la pédagogie
freiné qui encourage justement la prise
de parole des enfants il faut qu'il
disent les sentiments qu'il ressentent
s'ils sont bayonnés voilà et tout ça
donc moi je pense que voilà les agents
municipaux ils ont fait ce qu'ils ont pu
c'est pas la peine de de le taper
dessout de sa vie encore les frères pète
un coup sans non mais sans charier non
mais on dirait toujours que tu vas
mourir arrête un peu chose il est contre
l'autorité donc dès qu'on lève le petit
doigt forcément c'est un scandale voilà
faut appel les asso bon bon arrêtez de
parler de ça parce qu' il est pas bien
dé
tiens ah pour Noël 27 % des Français ont
demandé des avances sur salaire
justement ce sera pas bon pour
vous sera pas bon pour vous non mais je
dis sera pas la peine deer une petite
info comme
ça vous avez vu ça ou pas de la corida
appelle sa fiancée 30 minutes avant le
mariage pour lui dire qu'il change
d'AV est connu dans toute l'Andalousie
pour être un Tor de renom
mais samedi dernier alors que l'homme
devait épouser sa fiancée avec qui il
est en couple depuis une dizaine
d'années l'espagnool de 33 ans pris de
doute a décidé de l'appeler pour annuler
leur mariage 30 minutes seulement avant
la cérémonie une décision inattendue qui
a choqué une partie de
l'Espagne et qui a bouleversé la jeune
femme qui était attendu par les 500
invités elle ne peut plus s'arrêter de
pleurer de son côté le a annoncé qu'il
allait malgré tout payer les frais de
mariage ses levant à 70000
€endez les gars s'il était pas ça pe év
courageel courage rig par non mais c'est
pas ça mais le type se réveille alors
que ça fait 10 ans qu'ils sont ensemble
il est jamais trop tard pour 30 secondes
avant FO
Mar prère F ave tout
me moment il s dit B non et ben c'est
mieux que de se marier et de tromper sa
femme tout le
temps non mais déjà moi je trouve qu'il
a rien pour lui parce que déjà c'est une
star de corida ça dégûte il fait la
maltrait au animaux et je pense lui il
aurait d faire ah ouis oui il a rien
pour lui ça me dégoûte con en Espagne il
est comment phisiquement j'ai pas vu Go
sent la relation par ah ou bah oui
quelqu'un de jours du mariage vous l'avz
du mariage je pense qu'il y avait un
bail parallèle bien sûr lui il a eu
raison mais non mais je dis lui il a eu
raison pour les raisons que tu disais
mais pour elle elle était sur place sans
invités
l'umiliation il était pas sur place elle
elle était sur place 500 invités
l'humiliation devant les invités puis la
peine de cur hor moi j'ai de l'empathie
pour Carmen comment s'appelle
Carmen j'embrasse for qui est marié ici
d'ailleursne moi ça
m'ar bien frérot ma bralique non mais
c'est vrai tu t'es marié quand il y a 8
ans non c'est beau es toujours marié non
non pardon il y a 5 ans il y a 8 ans que
je avec ma FEM ah d'accord vous ê
toujours
marié 5 ans pard demain on va voir un
truc il divorce pendant une émission de
télé c'est ça et moi je me suis fait
laruer ça m''est arrivé 3 semaines avant
mon mariage c'est pas ou vra 3 semaines
vous étiez invité aUiage vu d'ailleurs
et le problème j'ai pu tout anai V non
je revu alors il aime pas il est faible
il est faible quand il un mec ou pas ton
je trouve que vous voyez mon ex très
souvent quand même non mais non mais
vous la croisez souvent bienvenu au
club
[Applaudissements]
drô la du gars qui fait quo non mais
mais tu devais marier elle n'est pas
venue ou tu non non non il devait se
marier il devait se marier et il est
rentré chez lui il est rentré chez lui
l'histoire est vrai écoutez bien 19h37
je la rencontre parce que je sais que
toi ça te fait trop de mal il rentre
chez lui plus aucune affaire elle avait
tout vidé elle a touténag il a plus
jamais revu la meuf exactement
sérieuxà et il m'a demandé d'enquêter
voilà et
alors sur l'qute il l' retroué mais
Guillaum elle n'a même pas laissé un mot
quelque chose d'explicatif la maison
vide la maison vide ah comme Michel
c'était quand c'était il y a 3 ans 2 ans
et demi mais tu avais tout payé 3
semaines avant SR j'ai pu tout me faire
rembourser sauf le traitur donc je suis
retrouvé avec 400 canapés au saumon chez
moi
c'estme j'éta Invité je t'ai invité on
était en train de se dire comment ça va
se passer tout ça terminé qui invité ici
à part moi moi moi non que moi pas que
moi frérot sa que je te jure
horrible relation il y a plus rien non
mais là il est heureux maintenant ça y
est je vais dire tu vois comme en vrai
ça met du temps de s'en mettre même si
on a quelqu'un hor moi tu m'invites
j'achète un costar des pompes tuannul tu
me rembourses
tout le torero a été beaucoup plus
courageux que que cette non non la p on
on va pas l'AC cabler la
Pau c'était pour vous défend
[Rires]
pourend ça fait partie de
l'enquête non mais j'ai pas tous les
éléments de l'enquête fait partie de
l'enquête mais c'est C méthodei Seris
pas en train de préparer un complément
de ququette non
mais pas du tout vous voulez dire il
était pas tout blanc est-ce que tu avais
le cul propre tu es pas tout blanc tu es
pas tout blanc tu es pas tout blanc
c'est quand quand on grimpe à
l'arbre sur ton téléphone ce n'est pas
non alors déjà non et ce n'est pas une
raison pour quitter la personne du jour
au Lain le dire au revoir et déménager
une maison entière elle a abandonné mes
chiens en plus pendant un weekend ils
étaient traumatisés les pauvres la
maison bah ouais parce que j'étais pas
là le weekend ils sont restés dans la
maison tu étais où toi F tu étais où oua
j'étais en en séminaire j'étais en
séminire S en séminaire sur la french
Rivier en séminire sur la French Riviera
évidemment elle a bien fait partir mais
ça se fait pas en vrai vous quittez pas
quelqu'un au bout de 13 ans sans dire au
revoir quand même non mais qu'est-ce que
tu en as fout j'ai passé mon bac avec
elle vous rendez compte bah oui 17 ans
oh la Ve ah oui j'avais 17 ans bah je
l'ai revu mais pourquoi parce que je
vais souvent dans un magasin où elle
elle vous parle et tout bien sûr mais
elle dit quoi bah ça va c'est tout il
est en plein de forme parle vous avez
son number et tout non pas du tout mais
non mais non mais dis pas de bêtises non
plus pas du tout je la vois mais je
pense qu'elle est je pense qu'elle
est-ce que vous sentez qu'elle est en
main quand vous la voz je pense qu'elle
a quelqu'un ah tu fais elle vous demande
des nouvelles de Guillaume et alors
comment il AR arrête tu es en train de
le briser là non mais il est passé à
autre chose B non mais il va avoir un
bébé les gars nouvelle meuf vous croyz
quoi extraordinaire nouvelle meu mais
c'est vrai magnifique elle elle a GL ou
pas POS beaucoup de questions quand même
elle est très gentil Jolie est jolie je
la regarde pas je regarde pas les des
PO moi JEE ah oui c'est c'est comme si
je voyais un
sac je ça contente d' comparer un
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
sac insupportable c'est insupportable
mais ça va mieux quand même bah oui mais
non c'est pas facile
ouire largué du jour au lendemain au
bout de 13 ans c'est très violent
heureusement que Jean-Michel n'est pas
payé à la vanne he parce qu'il s pas
payé
Cheron Marc est-ce que tu veux y aller
est-ce que tu veux rester avec nous n on
est bien quand tu es là écoute moi je
peux rester on a pas de sujet de tuas
pas il y a pas de sujet rasera
aujourd'hui d'accord ok franchement il a
pas de sujet de rasera donc tu peux
rester on peut rigoler tout le temps